the first thought that goes through our
heads is what's about to happen it's
funny how she can take something that
most of us just like forget about and
still finds a way to make it cool so
it's a recognizable Dynamic shift for
the audience and it's something that
keeps us engaged Drex here from Drex
Factor po sharing with you the love of
pois spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today I'm doing
a brand new reacts video The Twist this
time around I'm actually reacting to
something that just came out something
that I really enjoyed and that I hope
you you do as well before we dive in
though I just want to give a quick shout
out to the Friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyrot
teror light toys spinballs and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non- business Friends of the
channel Johnny Howard lay machinski and
Becca beckan thank you all so very much
for your support for my work and my
mission all right so when I started
doing my react series most of the videos
that I was reacting to were important
videos in the Canon of poise spinning
most of them were either a decade or
more old and I hadn't reacted to
anything that was comparatively recent
but all that changes today because there
was a glow stringing video that came out
about a week ago and that went really
viral and I would love to share with you
my thoughts on it this is a video
featuring artist Stacy ha at Electric
Daisy Carnival a few weeks ago and uh I
loved the heck out of this video so much
so that when people started asking about
it taking off um I made this very very
long post explaining everything that I
loved about it and I thought that a lot
of this stuff would be great for a
reacts video too most notably I think
that this is a video that is most
excellent in its treatment of pacing as
well as keeping the audience engaged as
well as the awesome things that can
happen when you move a camera around all
right so let's dive in and here's the
first thing that I want you to notice
here so the first few seconds here let's
go back and check that out for just a
second
cuz what's happening in the first like
two or 3 seconds of this video
absolutely nothing she's adjusting her
grip and she's getting ready for what
comes after why is this a good thing
because it arouses something called The
Curiosity Gap when we see her setting up
her glow sticks the first thought that
goes through our heads is what's about
to happen is this about to be cool is
this about to be a train wreck we want
to see what happens next So within the
first couple seconds she's giving us a
reason to tune in for a little bit
longer quite nice
nice and immediately we see that she's
got some good techniques as a glow
Stringer she's rapping o cool so did you
see what just happened there we got the
first few notes of a song that a lot of
us are familiar with this of course is
uh Sandstorm by Darude which I will
confess as a fin I will always have a
soft spot for yes Darude is a finish DJ
um and you'll not there was a moment
just a second ago where that popped up
on her face where it's clear that Stacy
knows too what just happened and she's
getting ready for it now I'm going to
let the build play out for a second so
you can see what happens and then I'm
going to go back through and show you
why it works
[Music]
[Applause]
that was awesome so let's talk about why
it was awesome I count at least three
specific phases to that build so let's
go back and explore them shall we first
and foremost right after Stacy has her
reaction where she realizes the song
about to happen here let me show you
what happens
next so that was her moment of
recognition what does she do she starts
bringing in the glow sticks close to her
body in fact she gets all the way to the
point where she's got the tethers
completely wrapped up and we get our
first discreet part of this build now
those of us who know the song are
waiting for the beat to drop and we're
right there with her but she's doing
something to help get us interested in
visually as well um she switched from
the original style that she started the
video with to something that it more
resembles uh freehand glow sticking I
think it's called freehand glow sticking
and she spends the first part of the
build just tracing the glow sticks
around her body and doing liquid dance
with it oh cool and now we've had our
first Dynamic shift in the glow sticks
as the build continues namely she's let
loose with the glow sticks and switched
to a style that contains some elements
of pois spinning and some elements of uh
glow sticking wraps so we have something
that like when the wraps happen they
feel a lot like the tracing that came
before it but we've also got something
that's added a little bit of volume to
what she's doing too so it's a
recognizable Dynamic shift for the
audience and it's something that keeps
us engaged
and cool we just entered the last part
of the build here uh where don't think
even she knows when the beat is going to
hit but what she's done is she's added
another layer of visual interest to what
she's doing um where we went from stuff
that was tucked in very very close to
her body to stuff that was starting to
move away from it now she's added to
both the volume as well as the levels of
her performance and added some windmills
and flowers and uh extensions to her
spinning we get contrasts with each part
of this build
crossers and
Giants and boom there it was and now
you'll notice she's adjusted her style
once again through the build we went
from tracers to wraps and some
traditional poy to doing big big big
moves windmills and Giants and now she's
brought back down her volume and levels
just a little bit why because it
contrasts the big levels the big volume
and high levels that she was just
playing with a second ago so it becomes
another Dynamic shift that keeps us
invested and interested in what she's
doing and of course now that the beat is
dropped she gets to go wild with
it nice and notice how we're getting
different perspectives on her she's
doing this too like in some cases she's
working in wall plane and she's facing
us and in some cases she's working in
wheel plane and we see her profile
another great way to explore the space
around her with uh with her body and to
give us additional uh kind of visual
information in the process cool now
we've got some tracery stuff so one
thing I do want to note here I feel like
what happens after the Beat Drops is
that Stacy's essentially doing something
similar to what the conductor of uh to
to what the uh person who composes a
symphony does where they introduce a few
musical themes that they then go on to
embellish upon Stacy definitely explored
three different discreet themes for
movement in the of that build and now
that the beat is dropped she's exploring
putting all of them together we're
seeing the tracers put together with the
wraps and the traditional POI and I
guarantee you anything we're going to
see some windmills tucked in here as
well and of course I'm great behind the
back stuff I'm terrible behind the back
she's way better at it oh there was the
windmill who called
it nice and the
Giants can I also just say for a second
that I love the way that she does
meltdowns um a lot of people tend tend
to keep their upper bodies like
basically just straight As A Rod as
they're uh performing their meltdowns
her entire body is getting into it we
see it like basically thrash around a
little in space as though it has an
opinion on the movements that it's
performing in order to do the Meltdown
fantastic also I love her feet marching
there to the beat that's a fantastic
touch um she does something that I wish
a lot more flow artists would do and
that she moves her feet and she makes
moving her body around as important as
moving her props around that's part of
why this video is so fun to
watch also notice as she's walking
around the camera follows her and we get
to see parts of the background this adds
more interest to us cuz we're curious
what else is there behind
[Music]
her that was
sick that also has to be the steei uh
reverse thread the needle I think I've
ever seen it's funny how she can take
something that most of us just like
forget about after we've been spinning
for a couple years and still finds a way
to make it cool nicely done also like
check out the look on her face as she's
doing all this she's having a freaking
blast and that helps us as the audience
to be there with her and now the video
is winding
down and of course the very last shot of
it is a massive smile on her face
fantastic all right so here's a few
takeaways from this video that I think
are particularly important and help to
explain why it went viral so number one
the video really engages our curiosity
Gap and it does an amazing job of paying
it off not only within those first few
seconds of the video are we intrigued
about where it's going next but every
single time that Stacy introduces a new
idea it's just in time to keep our
attention and what's even better as time
goes on in the video she finds ways to
call back to those ideas and keep us
engaged number two this video is shot
fantastically it's well lit enough that
we can see the performer really well we
can see those wonderful Expressions on
her face we can see her dancing and
marching her feet in place as well as
moving around the space that she has
access to the camera follows her around
and that adds an additional level of
interest to the whole thing and finally
she knows how to put together really
satisfying techniques she knows how to
take each of these individual discret
ideas for how you can perform with glow
sticks or POI and pulls them together
into a new mashup that I personally
think is just really cool she's got her
rapid wraps down she has all of her
extensions meltdowns and all that kind
of stuff down and two she gives us a
little bit of some more freehand style
which like seeing all these pieces put
together in this particular way is
really really satisfying I don't think
it's any coincidence that this video
blew up it's wonderfully composed it is
wonderfully sh got and quite frankly the
skills in it are fantastic too so Stacy
well done here this also isn't the only
awesome video that she's produced I
don't even think that this is the first
video of hers that I got into uh so I'll
go ahead and leave links to her socials
down in the description because you
should go check her out do yourself a
favor so I hope you all can take some
lessons from Stacy here and uh go forth
and create some awesome videos yourself
maybe something that you learned here
will help you go viral you never know
and Stacy beautiful job please keep
these amazing videos coming they are
such a pleasure to watch and uh it's
definitely inspiring me to explore some
more glow stringing stuff myself keep up
the good work do you want to see me
react to more contemporary videos uh
leave me a comment and let me know or
let me know if there are some older
videos that you would love to see me
react to as well I'm happy to do both
did you get anything out of this video
please leave a like comment share and
subscribe to keep the conversation going
and of course to help people find this
video and to help my channel grow this
video would not be possible without the
kind support of all of these amazing
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon and they along
with people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
amazing support do you like my videos do
you like my flow sessions Vlogs reacts
videos Etc I'm on a mission to try and
bring po spinning and flow Arts to The
Wider world and help people connect with
their brains and their bodies as
creative individuals so help me do it
head on over to
patreon.com drexfactor poo and sign up
you can do that at the link down in the
description or the card that just popped
up if you are watching on YouTube uh
that once again is uh
patreon.com dfactor pooy there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and even better you'll be
helping me out in my mission so go check
that out please and thank you if you
want to check out more reacts videos
that I have done in the past uh there
should be a playlist of them linked to
down in the description or uh this
bottom link on screen if you're watching
on YouTube also if you're watching on
YouTube uh the algorithm thinks that you
will like this top video right here so
give that a shot and see if that is up
your alley uh thank you so much for
watching uh make sure to subscribe and
also make sure to get out and flow today
and I will see you with a brand new
video on Wednesday thanks so thanks so
much for watching once again have a good
one peace